we got Valentine's Day coming up want to
be the best boyfriend ever this year I'm
thinking quiet at home make your
favorite meal cuddle it makes the
fireplace good for you that sounds
really simple you know what I'm gonna do
I'm planning a romantic picnic in the
park
followed by ice skating oh it's the love
ice skating back when I was like five
you know what I'm gonna do her favorite
bands gonna be in town that weekend I
think I'll get tickets to the show
and then afterwards get a couples
massage performed by the band oh wow I
hope the band washes their hands after
the show you know what I'm gonna do I'm
renting a cabin in the mountains so we
can go skiing together on snow I made
with a snow machine I really hope she
doesn't get frostbite you know what I'm
gonna do we're gonna go to the San Diego
Zoo take pictures with all the animals
she loved us animals and then we're
gonna set them all free oh my goodness
that sounds really dangerous you know
what I'm gonna do you're renting a
hot-air balloon so we can go ballooning
over the Alps while projecting her
favorite movie on the clouds well I hope
she doesn't get hit in the face with a
bird damn it congratulations you've won
the best boyfriend a war